at the bottom of the hill make a right
continue straight ahead
at the next intersection turn left
my name is Karen Jacobson and I'm known
as the only woman men will take
directions from
my speaking voice ended up in over a
billion GPS and smartphone devices
giving directions to people around the
world you have reached your destination
well I'll take you right back to the
beginning I'm originally from Makai
which is a town in North Queensland near
Australia's Great Barrier Reef I wanted
to become a professional singer and move
to America and I did Follow that dream
to New York and not long after I moved
there there was an audition and a client
was looking for a native Australian
female voice over artist living in the
northeast of the United States
and I went to that audition and I got
the job proceed to the route proceed to
the root proceed to the roof
at the time I was told that the
Australian voice was a high priority
because the Australian accent was
considered the most Pleasant English
speaking accent
to listen to which is pretty cool
turn left at the roundabout turn right
there was a huge script a massive script
and the team of Engineers had figured
out every combination of syllables
possible for me to record so they could
chop that up and create this voice
system based on my speaking voice I went
into the booth and recorded these
different lines at the next intersection
turn left at the roundabout turn right
you have reached your destination what
are some other ones let me think oh
everybody's favorite
recalculating I had to say the word
approximately approximately
168 times in a row there is a red light
camera approaching I like to keep people
safe
when I'm asked to use the voice
I do because it's fun
my voice is going to live on forever
wow the power is going to go to my head
I mean that's mind-blowing really isn't
it
you have reached your destination